a fourth grade teacher is in slight hot
water right now
because she passed out a radical leftist
critical race theory inspired equity
survey
and told students to hide the survey
from their parents my name is hayley
osgar
i was in fourth grade at riverview
intermediate school last year
during distance learning i was asked to
complete that equity survey
my teacher said that i could not skip
any questions even when i didn't
understand
one question asked us what genderfire we
identified with
i was very confused along with a lot of
other classmates
a boy in my class asked my teacher if
his mom could explain the question to
him because
even after the teacher explained that he
still didn't understand
my teacher told him that he was not
allowed to ask his mom
and that we could not repeat any of the
questions to her parents
i want the school board to know how
uncomfortable and nervous this made
my mom always tells me i can tell her
anything
but she also tells me i can trust my
teachers too
being asked to hide this from my mom
made me feel very uncomfortable
i was doing like i was doing something
wrong thank you
i love it i love great job to this girl
you know very often
i i don't like it when little kids go up
and speak at the school board or speak
at the
town meeting or whatever and give some
impassioned political speech and then
people on the left and the right say wow
yes she's speaking truth to power or
whatever
because i think that kids don't really
know anything and so they shouldn't be
giving political speeches
but that's not what this girl is doing
this girl is not giving her
opinion about some political issue
she is just reporting facts that
actually were being
suppressed by the school so the school
is passing out this
radical leftist equity survey which has
all sorts of hideous premises in it
especially on issues of race
and explicitly told
do not show this to your parents why
because the parents will object because
it's
radical leftism it's brainwashing these
kids and because the teacher believes
that
the school has the exclusive right to
educate kids and parents have no rights
whatsoever
so this girl comes up good honor and
says
this is a big problem how did this
happen well the school district in
minnesota a lot of these
radical policies are coming out of
minnesota i'm noticing
and the sartel saint-stephen district
they hired the leftist equity alliance
minnesota
to conduct an 80-thousand 000
audit on quote racial inequities within
the school district
this according to alpha news and then
students were required to complete a
survey for the audit and parents
taxpayers were not not permitted to know
about this kind of a survey
when the left tells you that critical
race theory is not being taught in
schools
remember this story we covered another
story like this yesterday what the
schools are doing is they're going out
and they are hiring critical race
theorists if they are hiring people
who are operating very much within the
legal analytical framework of critical
race theory
to go in and rewrite curricula in
schools
and they're paying these people
handsomely to do it
and then your kids are being taught the
products of that
revision that is happening do not let
them
gaslight you hey i'm glad you like that
clip
seriously i'm very glad that pleases me
greatly
i would be even happier if you would
watch the whole show it is called
an offer you can't refuse go check it
out it's here on youtube
it's on apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play myspace xanga live journal
hotmail
linux i don't know it's everywhere go
get it subscribe and by the way you can
still order my number one national
bestselling book
speechless controlling words controlling
mine see you next time
[Music]
you